Speaker 1: So the question is, who is the
next big star of the Republican Party?
Well, there was a phenomenal piece written
this week by a good good friend of mine, Cliff
Schecter, writing for The Daily Beast.
The piece is titled Dan Crenshaw is the Trumpist
of the wannabe new Trumps.
And in the piece, he talks about the fact
that sure, we've got other conservatives out
there, kind of, you know, hinting at and testing
the waters.
You got your Nikki Haley, of course you got
you, Ted Cruz.
Maybe they're the ones to take up the mantle
of Trumpism here in the U.S.
And then, of course, you've got the really
wackier ones.
You're Marjorie Taylor Greene's in your budgets,
in your Gates's.
But none of them, Cliff, points out.
Have what Dan Crenshaw has.
Dan Crenshaw.
For the most part, is not as openly extreme
as some of those other individuals.
He knows how to speak to an audience he effectively
has, as Cliff points out, what Trump had.
That charisma.
Coupled with, of course, shamelessness and
cruelty.
But it's the charisma, it's his ability to
play to an audience, much like Donald Trump
did.
That is what makes Crenshaw so dangerous,
and of course, most likely the heir apparent
to Donald Trump's entire political movement.
You know, Crenshaw recently did an interview
where he called out the performance artists
of the Republican Party.
And he told us we know who they are.
He didn't want to name any names.
He doesn't want to make any waves because
he's smart.
I'll give him that.
He is smart.
He's good at what he does, but it's pretty
obvious that he is talking about your Marjorie
Taylor Greene's in your law.
And Bob, it's the people in Madison, Cawthorn,
the people who are out there just to get famous.
They just want people to know their names.
And as he pointed out correctly, by the way,
they're not doing anything legislatively,
OK, they're not actually furthering the conservative
cause, as he says.
And his ability to call these people out and
seem as he's calling them out, like the rational
choice, like the best alternative is what
does make him so incredibly dangerous as a
potential candidate in the future.
And then, of course, you have the performative
side.
Crenshaw has something the rest of them don't.
He's got military credentials, and as Cliff
Schecter points out again.
He's got the battle wound.
He's got the eye patch, and I'm not saying
that to attack him, but that eyepatch is a
constant reminder that he served, that he
went over there and fought the fight that
these other conservatives only push from behind
their legislative desks.
That makes a big difference with these Republican
candidates, somebody who can go out there
and say, Oh, well, you say you support the
military, but I was actually in it.
I fought it and I live with the ramifications
of it.
He's got that tough guy persona that Donald
Trump could only pretend to have.
And of course, you do have the performance
artist in him, right?
We've all seen the videos, the Crenshaw's
point out put out, excuse me himself, you
know, rappelling down from the ceilings, acting
like some kind of Avenger slash secret agent
guy.
This big, tough bravado of only I can save
this.
Which is kind of similar to what Donald Trump
actually said when he first ran for president.
Only I can do this.
And that's what Crenshaw is putting out there.
He appeals to the Trumpers, but he can act
sane enough because I do think to his credit,
I think he is a sane person.
But I think he knows when to turn on the crazy
and turn it off.
And that's what separates him from the rest
of the pack.
That's what makes him different from a Marjorie
Taylor Greene.
It's what makes him different from a Ted Cruz,
because Ted Cruz has gone full blown into
all of this, he doesn't know who he is.
But Crenshaw can turn it on and turn it off
like that.
And as Cliff points out, that's something
that makes him incredibly valuable to the
conservative movement.
And, of course, makes him incredibly scary
as a potential Republican candidate in the
future.
I'm Farron Cousins.
Follow me on YouTube at youtube.com, slash
the ring of fire and youtube.com slash fair
and balanced across social media platforms
Twitter, Facebook, Instagram at fair and balanced.
You're watching the David Pakman show.
We'll be right back with more